اما البقاء والعمل لساعات طويله او انهاء
الخدمه بلهجه حاده كحده تصرفاته هكذا خاطب
الملياردير الامريكي الماسك موظفه في منصه
تويتر
من جديد والنجاح في عالم يتزايد التنفس
سنحتاج الى ان نكون متشددين للغايه هذا
يعني العمل لساعه طويله بكثافه عاليه لكن
موظفي العصفور الازرق سئموت تصرفات مالكه
الجديد فان لم يكن هناك مجال للحوار
وابداء الراي طريق الاستقاله كان اسهل
واقصر تقارير عده تشير الى ان مئات من
الموظفين قد مسقلاتهم ونسبه كبيره منهم
كانوا من المهندسين المسؤولين عن صيانه
الخدمه في موقع تويتر
التداعيات المتسارعه التي تشهدها منصه
تويتر مثلت زوبعه بداها ماسك بسلسله
تغييرات وقرارات تسببت بفوضه داخليه
للشركه انتقل صداها خارجيا لمستخدمي
المنصه بدات بطرد 50 من الموظفين الذين
كان يبلغ عددهم
7,500 شخص والغاء سياسه داخليه كانت تسمح
بالعمل من المنزل وفرض ساعات عمل طويله
الملياردير الامريكي بدا اخيرا بالشعور
بمالات خياراته القاسيه ليعلن ان جميع
المباني مغلقه مؤقتا ويمنع دخول جميع
الموظفين اعلان عزاهم موقع بزنس انسايدر
الى مخاوف الملك الجديد للشركه من احتمال
حدوث تخريب داخلي واضطرابات
لكن قرار الموظفين المباغته بالاستقاله
دفع ماسك للاجتماع مع مجموعه من العمال
الذين اعتبرت ادوارهم حاسمه في محاوله
الاقناعهم بالبقاء وفق صحيفه نيورك تايمز
هجره العقول المحركه لموقع تويتر انتقلت
ايضا لبعض مستخدمين منصه الذين بداوا
بالفعل في توديع تويتر وسط توقعاته بمشكله
تقنيه ضخمه تعصف بانظمه تويتر
لقرابه 16 عاما روان حمزه العربيه